هو واحد من اشهر المسلسلات السعوديه لا
بلوه العربيه واللي صار خلص من كلاسيكيات
الدراما ناقش مختلف القضايا الاجتماعيه
للمجتمع السعودي على مدار 17 سنه فبدا من
93 وتوقف في 2008 كم سنه ورجع بعدها في
2011 وتوقف بعد عرض الجزء ال18 ومن اشهر
كشف رئيس هيئه الترفيه المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ عن مفاجاه بعوده المسلسل في جزء
جديد في رمضان المقبل بعد توقف 12 سنه
وبمشاركه نجميه كمان ناصر القصبي وعبد
الله السدحان وليله امس نشر الاعلان
الترويجي للمسلسل اللي هو واحد من اكثر
الاعمال المنتظره وللجمهور مترقبها ومترقب
الجديد اللي حيعملوه بعد كل سنين التوقف
هذه هو الاعلان اعتمد على الشخصيات
الكرتونيه لاعلان عوده طاش
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حماس الناس على الاعلان هذا مترجم في
المشاهدات اكثر من مليون مشاهده على حسابي
ابو ناصر اللي نشر الاعلان هذا غير الكويت
والكومنتات وهذه عينه من كمان حماس
الجمهور لعوده طاش
[موسيقى]